hey what's up guys i'm sebastian yatra
and i'm here with buzzfeed to read
my thirst tweets
[Music]
i get like nervous reading these things
sebastian yatra is so underrated
means like a great voice why must i
shave my legs to go out tonight i'm not
going out with sebastian yatra
so who do i have to impress you gotta
you don't have to impress anyone you
just i don't know just
feel good about yourself and i mean
you also dress up for yourself it says i
want sebastian yatra
to sing me to sleep well that's nice of
her
um what could i sing her to sleep
well i can sing like a valid version of
chike that i like
so it basically says am i the only one
that feels the big
dick vibes that sebastian yatrick is
next
who tweets these things maluma and
sebastian yatra
own my
[Laughter]
this is good i like this series okay
sebastian yatra is so hot like this is
so
out of character for me to tweet this
but wow i'm glad i made you tweet
something
out of character some people make me
want to tweet so i'm out of character
stuff too
all in caps sebastian yatra
can choke me and then a bunch of like
faces like this and this phase like
the one and then fire that sounds
intense
okay that's probably the most intense
tweet so far
i want sebastian to plow me
like a tractor how do you plow someone
like a tractor
you're crazy me fantastic
my sexual fantasy is semester yeah
it will be a lie to say i'm that that's
not a
fun tweet to read sebastian yatra is
symbol thank you it means i'm underrated
as a sex symbol
well i'm actually doing a a series right
now that i'm gonna be recording for
netflix and i have to look very good i'm
working out more than ever so i hope my
sex symbol vibes grow look all i'm
saying is that sebastian yatcher has got
some nice ass teeth
and if he wanted me to i don't know lick
them
i wouldn't say no
you're making me feel weird about my
i'ma drink water
okay buzzfeed this is the final tweet
it's gonna be the
thirstiest now according to my sources
and what i've been told so
um here we go sebastian yatra can
impregnate me with the antichrist
with jalapeno on his and i'd still say
thank you daddy
that's just weird well thank you so much
buzzfeed love you guys this is by far
the time in an interview where i've said
the biggest amount of bad words and
sexual things and it is thanks to all
these people
that tweeted with thirst love you guys
and
thank you for thinking about me in these
special ways oh and guys don't forget to
check out my
latest release chicago remix with will i
am
and wanna you guys are gonna love this
song because it's
pure good energy and vibes and happiness
and party
you